Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
"France-Allemagne :
pourquoi ça tangue ?"
France-Allemagne : un couple ?
Un tandem ?
Une relation au coeur de l'Europe ?
Un trait d'union fondateur ?
Le pouvoir de durée
de l'Europe politique,
il fallait bien cela,
après trois effroyables conflits :
la guerre de 1870,
la Première Guerre mondiale,
la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
ont mis aux prises
ces deux nations,
qui vont se retrouver
pour bâtir de concert
une Europe de la paix,
de la coopération
et de la prospérité.
Contrairement aux légendes,
sur une alliance quasi naturelle
et harmonieuse
entre nos deux pays,
il y a toujours eu entre eux
des hauts et des bas.
Une émulation politique respective,
à base de frictions conjoncturelles
et structurelles,
sur l'économie, les institutions,
la stratégie vis-à-vis
des Etats-Unis,
de la Russie,
de la Chine, de l'OTAN.
Pourquoi s'en étonner ?
Car comme l'énonce
le philosophe Pierre Manent,
"Nos nations diffèrent
par leur histoire politique."
Cette distinction historique
n'aura pas empêché
de faire de l'Europe
une communauté intégrée
de peuples et de nations.
Une puissance commerciale
et même militaire, une union
territoriale et politique
que nous envient l'Afrique,
les Amériques,
et l'Asie.
A l'aube de ce 3e millénaire,
marqué par des crises économiques
et financières,
et des conflits guerriers,
notamment la guerre en Ukraine,
et sans oublier
la pandémie Covid-19,
et bien que la coopération
franco-allemande fonctionne,
nous assistons à un essoufflement
de la relation franco-allemande.
Pourquoi et dans quels domaines ?
C'est ce que nous allons voir
avec mes invités,
que je vous présente.
Hans-Dieter Lucas,
ambassadeur
de la République fédérale
d'Allemagne en France.
Pierre Lellouche,
vous êtes ancien ministre,
chargé des Affaires européennes
et expert international.
Edouard Guillaud,
vous êtes amiral et ancien CEMA,
chef d'état-major des armées.
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne,
vous êtes ambassadeur.
Vous l'avez été
dans de nombreux pays européens
et ancien secrétaire
général du Quai d'Orsay.
Alors, malgré une activité
diplomatique chargée,
ces derniers temps,
nous l'avons vu avec la célébration
du traité de l'Elysée,
et plus récemment,
avec une rencontre coordonnée
avec le président Zelensky,
à laquelle assistait
à Paris,
monsieur Olaf Scholz,
et à l'épreuve des conflits,
l'axe franco-allemand fonctionne.
Il n'est pas rompu.
Mais il ne régente plus
l'Union européenne.
Il a perdu de son élan politique,
et on dirait même,
de sa force émotionnelle.
A votre avis, pourquoi,
monsieur Lucas ?
-Je ne partage pas
cette vue-là,
cette perspective.
J'ai l'impression
que la relation franco-allemande
est basée sur un socle très solide,
et particulièrement les...
Le dernier Conseil des ministres
franco-allemands,
les célébrations à l'occasion
du 60e anniversaire
du traité de l'Elysée
ont démontré
qu'il y a une vision partagée
de l'Europe, c'est-à-dire
la nécessité, vraiment, de bâtir,
de construire une Europe
qui est plus souveraine
dans un contexte
global extrêmement difficile
sur le plan politique,
avec des réformes institutionnelles,
sur le plan technologique
et économique,
c'est-à-dire renforcer aussi
l'indépendance,
la souveraineté économique
de l'Union européenne,
et troisièmement,
en ce qui concerne la nécessité
de construire une Europe
de la défense.
-On va rentrer
dans le détail.
-Il y a un bon nombre de projets
très concrets franco-allemands,
au service de l'Europe.
-Pierre Lellouche,
vous partagez cette analyse ?
Tout va bien ?
-Je crois que
c'est pas que tout va mal.
Je pense que les liens...
-J'ai demandé si tout va bien.
-...sont extrêmement importants
pour la suite
des opérations en Europe,
mais je crois que le...
La relation franco-allemande
a été affectée, très profondément,
bien avant la guerre en Ukraine,
par le changement
dans la corrélation des forces
entre nos deux pays.
L'Allemagne, unifiée,
s'est puissamment...
D'abord, elle a été unifiée,
un énorme changement
par rapport à la période précédente.
J'avais écrit à l'époque,
là-dessus, à 30 ans.
Surtout, elle s'est renforcée,
de façon...
de façon considérable,
alors que nous nous affaiblissions.
Il y a un différentiel qui, moi,
me préoccupait il y a 10 ans,
quand j'étais
au commerce extérieur.
Je voyais le déficit plonger.
Aujourd'hui, il atteint
160 milliards d'euros,
quand l'Allemagne,
avant les histoires de gaz,
était à + 200 milliards,
donc on avait
un delta de quelque chose
comme 300 milliards d'euros
entre la France et...
et l'Allemagne,
c'est-à-dire 15 points de PIB.
Considérable.
Donc, une puissance
industrielle en Allemagne
très importante,
alors que nous nous affaiblissions.
Et puis,
je dirais aussi le fait
qu'avec l'élargissement de l'Europe,
et plus encore après la guerre
ou avec la guerre en Ukraine,
l'Allemagne a retrouvé son rôle
de pivot
au centre de l'Europe.
Nous avons été quelque peu
marginalisés à la périphérie.
Sigmar Gabriel, l'ancien ministre
des Affaires étrangères,
l'a dit publiquement
et je partage tout à fait cet avis.
Il y a eu une espèce
de déport de la France,
l'Allemagne retrouvant
son rôle pivot,
entourée par toute l'Europe centrale
et son influence,
son poids économique,
et donc, ça, ça crée des tensions,
ce qui donne aussi à l'Allemagne
la possibilité
d'affirmer de plus en plus
une autonomie dans ses décisions,
que nous avons subie,
dans beaucoup de cas,
qu'il s'agisse de finance,
d'énergie.
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
-Un tout dernier point.
Ce qui, aujourd'hui,
caractérise encore plus
cette relation franco-allemande,
qui est, encore une fois,
très importante, c'est le fait
qu'avec l'Ukraine,
le centre de gravité de l'Europe
a complètement basculé
vers la Pologne,
les Baltes et les Scandinaves,
et marginalisé
pas seulement la France,
mais la France
et l'Allemagne ensemble,
dont le rôle pilote
de cet ensemble,
que nous avons créé ensemble,
est maintenant, j'allais dire,
presque secondaire,
ce qui fait qu'avec le rôle
de la Pologne et des Baltes,
on voit arriver un nouveau membre
dans l'Union européenne :
les Etats-Unis d'Amérique.
-On va, si vous permettez,
Pierre Lellouche,
rester sur la première question,
avec Maurice Gourdault-Montagne.
Les commentaires sont nombreux,
en France et en Allemagne,
qui disent que l'Allemagne s'éloigne
de la voie communautaire.
Vous le pensez,
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne ?
-Je ne le crois pas.
Je crois que ce qui a été dit
par Pierre Lellouche
et l'ambassadeur me paraît juste.
Une dissymétrie entre la France
et l'Allemagne s'est accentuée.
Il y a un besoin permanent
de se réadapter
et de recomposer ensemble.
C'est une dynamique qui nécessite
un effort politique.
Ce n'est pas la 1re fois
que la relation
franco-allemande subit des chocs.
Là, la guerre en Ukraine,
qui change, qui bouleverse
les centres de gravité,
les modèles économiques,
et peut-être les modèles politiques
franco-allemands.
A nous de rebondir là-dessus.
Nous avons des institutions
qui encadrent
la relation franco-allemande
et nous permettent
de nous parler.
Nous sommes très différents.
Les Allemands, vous l'avez dit,
ne sont pas les Français.
Nous sommes extrêmement différents.
Un de mes premiers patrons
m'avait dit :
"Les Allemands ne sont pas
"des Français qui parlent allemand."
C'est la vérité.
La relation franco-allemande,
à Berlin, je l'appelais
"un combat de chaque jour".
Les Allemands sont là.
Nous, ici.
Il faut se rapprocher.
Quand la volonté politique est là,
on trouve, encore faut-il
un rapport de force où la France
a les moyens d'affirmer
qui elle est.
Nous avons faibli,
dans une certaine mesure,
mais la politique,
c'est l'art précisément
de surmonter
ses contradictions.
-Votre avis, Edouard Guillaud ?
-Je serai non pas
un peu plus nuancé, mais me plaçant
sous un angle
un peu plus militaire,
nous sommes partis,
dans les années 70-80,
d'une dissymétrie assumée,
parce que nous étions déjà membre
du Conseil de sécurité, membre
permanent,
avec droit de veto,
car nous avions
un outil militaire,
alors que l'Allemagne avait,
comme disait l'inspecteur général
de la Bundeswehr,
au début des années 2000,
son armée,
c'était des citoyens en uniforme,
et il s'en désolait.
C'était le début des affaires
en Afghanistan. Cette dissymétrie
a disparu ou est en train,
petit à petit, de disparaître.
Il y a plusieurs moments
qui l'ont marquée.
La chute du mur de Berlin.
Ich war dabei.
J'y étais, ce soir-là,
donc c'était quand même
assez extraordinaire.
Ensuite,
il y a eu les interventions,
y compris par l'Allemagne,
sur le théâtre ex-yougoslave.
Puis,
l'envoi de troupes
à l'extérieur de l'Europe,
par la Bundeswehr.
C'est l'Afghanistan.
Après trois ans,
Wolfgang Schneiderhan me dit :
"J'ai enfin des soldats",
alors que les modalités
d'utilisation
des forces allemandes
n'étaient pas du tout les mêmes
et Pierre Lellouche s'en souvient,
puisque nous y étions ensemble,
que celles des forces françaises,
ou des autres forces européennes
et puis,
maintenant, effectivement,
on a continué
avec les affaires africaines.
Et maintenant,
la guerre en Ukraine...
...change encore la donne,
donc si nous partons
d'un état zéro
par rapport à il y a 30 ans,
il y a une dissymétrie
qui est apparue. A mon avis,
en réalité, ça rééquilibre...
L'Allemagne retrouve...
...une place normale.
-Au-delà
de votre unanimité là-dessus,
en 70 ans
de construction européenne,
il y a eu
de très grandes choses
qui ont été faites.
La CECA : Communauté
économique du charbon
et de l'acier,
le marché commun, l'euro,
Maastricht, etc.
Est-ce que vous pourriez citer
une grande réalisation au cours
de ces deux dernières décennies ?
A la fois en termes
d'approfondissement politique
et d'élargissement
politique qui a été bloqué
au sud avec la Turquie,
et à l'est, aujourd'hui,
avec la guerre ?
-Moi, je peux vous donner
un exemple que j'ai vécu.
C'était pendant la crise de 2008.
Avec beaucoup de mal...
Nicolas Sarkozy a eu beaucoup de mal
à convaincre Angela Merkel
qu'il fallait sauver la Grèce,
et en même temps,
l'Union européenne et l'euro,
contre toutes les réserves possibles
du côté allemand : Banque centrale,
mon homologue...
Il y avait des règles,
on les appliquait, etc..
On y est arrivés.
Au forceps,
mais on y est arrivés.
On a réussi à convaincre l'Allemagne
de mutualiser... On a mis
énormément d'argent, beaucoup
de centaines de milliards d'euros
pour sauver l'Allemagne et l'euro.
-La Grèce.
-Et ça, c'était contraire
à toutes les règles allemandes
sur la bonne gestion de la monnaie.
Donc ça, on l'a fait.
Après, il y a des choses
qui vont moins bien,
honnêtement, aujourd'hui.
L'amiral parlait
de la montée en puissance
de l'Allemagne en matière
de défense, nécessaire
pour la défense européenne...
-On l'abordera
dans le détail.
-Mais bon, franchement,
si je regarde le catalogue
des programmes en commun,
je suis dévasté :
beaucoup de choses
qu'on devait faire ensemble
ne se sont pas faites
en raison de la position allemande,
qu'il s'agisse du char,
de l'hélicoptère, etc.,
des patrouilles aériennes,
de la surveillance maritime,
etc.
C'est pas bon. On a...
une divergence, y compris
sur la défense antiaérienne.
Il reste plus que le projet
d'avion de combat futur,
mais c'est pas bon.
-On va en parler
en détail.
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne,
je voudrais avoir un avis,
votre avis personnel.
Le traité de Nice...
...a voulu
un certain approfondissement
des relations.
Il a été suivi, après,
du traité de Lisbonne, etc.,
mais est-ce qu'il n'y a pas eu,
à ce niveau-là,
une dissension,
qui a entraîné une fêlure,
dans la mesure où
la représentativité de l'Allemagne
a été augmentée, et je me souviens,
en tant que journaliste,
qu'Helmut Schmidt
n'était pas favorable
à cette chose-là.
-Je crois qu'il fallait...
-Pardonnez-moi.
-Vous avez raison
de rappeler ces souvenirs
du traité de Nice,
qui s'est soldé par un échec,
puisqu'il a fallu passer
à autre chose,
la Convention européenne,
sous la présidence
de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing...
-Qui a échoué.
-...qui n'a pas abouti,
et qui, néanmoins, a permis
d'aboutir à ce qui est devenu
plus tard le traité de Lisbonne,
donc, une réorganisation
des équilibres au sein
de l'UE.
C'était indispensable.
On ne pouvait pas continuer
à faire semblant
de dire que l'Allemagne pesait
moins lourd dans l'Union européenne,
lorsqu'il s'agissait
de prendre des décisions,
qu'un certain nombre d'autres pays.
Des dispositifs ont été créés
avec des majorités qualifiées
pour servir de blocage
en cas de décisions
qui ne correspondaient pas
à la tendance
qui devait se dégager
dans un consensus.
Donc, c'est une...
C'est un système
qui n'est pas parfait,
qui trouve son équilibre,
mais on ne peut pas nier la réalité.
Aujourd'hui, et c'est le cas
dans les relations internationales,
il y a les réalités.
Quand un pays pèse plus lourd,
ça doit être pris en compte.
Après ça, on s'organise.
C'est le rôle de la France
et de l'Allemagne,
dans ce tandem, c'est le mot
que je préfère, et d'ailleurs,
très souvent, quand j'étais
en Allemagne, je citais
ce qui est un tandem
dans les pays du Maghreb, notamment,
où on dit qu'un attelage, un tandem,
peu importe s'il y a un chameau
et un âne, c'est de tirer
dans la même direction.
Je ne sais pas qui a quel rôle,
mais la France et l'Allemagne
sont un attelage qui, pour l'Europe,
tire dans une direction commune.
C'est ce que nous faisons.
-Mais vous regrettez
ou pas ce qui s'est passé à Nice ?
-Je ne regrette rien
de ce qui s'est passé.
Je pense que les équilibres
politiques du moment
nous ont permis
d'aboutir à un résultat,
qui a créé une dynamique.
Après, il faut s'adapter.
Il y a un élargissement potentiel
de l'Europe,
qu'il faut regarder ensemble,
des équilibres,
des centres de gravité,
qui se déplacent.
Il faut les prendre en compte.
Il n'y a rien à regretter.
Vous demandiez un exemple.
Je pourrais citer Airbus,
un succès majeur.
-On va rentrer
dans le détail.
-Les principaux échanges
en Europe se font
entre la France et l'Allemagne.
Les investissements,
étrangers...
-On va parler de ça dans le détail.
Je voudrais laisser...
Monsieur Lucas,
vous avez un mot à dire à propos
du traité de Nice ?
-Non, je partage tout à fait
ce qui a été dit
par Maurice Gourdault-Montagne,
mais je voudrais revenir
sur votre question :
est-ce qu'il y a
des projets récents ?
Je mentionnais,
dans ce contexte,
cette initiative franco-allemande
pour le plan de relance.
C'était vraiment un pas majeur,
n'est-ce pas,
ce programme de 500 milliards
d'euros,
et de la part de l'Allemagne,
c'était une grande concession,
la mutualisation partielle
des dettes.
Ca, c'était vraiment
un grand pas pour nous.
-La suite de 2008.
-C'était il y a...
trois ans,
et aussi, encore une fois,
si vous analysez le discours
de Prague, du chancelier Scholz,
et ce que le président
de la République a dit
dans un discours à la Sorbonne,
il y a beaucoup de points communs.
-On va parler de ça.
Vous allez voir.
Nous venons de voir
la pensée profonde
de deux grands écrivains,
Victor Hugo et Goethe.
Ils auraient pu se rencontrer,
par exemple, à Weimar,
ce qui montre...
Pourquoi
j'ai pris ces deux écrivains ?
C'est pour montrer que...
les relations littéraires,
les relations entre hommes,
entre femmes, etc., peuvent avoir
une importance considérable.
Alors, la relation franco-allemande,
elle est identifiée,
à juste titre,
à des couples, qui partagent
et qui partageaient
une connivence forte.
De Gaulle et Adenauer avaient
une même analyse politique.
On célèbre le 60e anniversaire
du traité de l'Elysée :
c'est leur oeuvre.
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
et Helmut Schmidt avaient
une commune analyse
économique.
Mitterrand et Kohl se retrouvaient
sur le terrain historique.
Puis, la diplomatie l'a emporté
sur l'imagination,
sur la grandeur politique.
Une certaine indifférence a suivi,
et des bifurcations,
que l'on va analyser
dans le détail.
Mais qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ce...
Vous pensez qu'il n'y a plus,
si on peut dire,
cette espèce de relation élective
qu'il y a eue
à travers les grands couples
de l'histoire
franco-allemande ?
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne ?
-Un grand couple, pas cité,
Chirac et Schroeder,
ont été d'accord ensemble...
-Sur un point.
-...pour refuser la guerre en Irak,
ce qui n'était pas rien,
de résister à la pression
mise sur des peuples
et des gouvernements
pour les faire entrer
dans une guerre
qui n'avait aucune raison d'être,
une guerre d'agression.
Ca nous a permis
de beaucoup avancer.
Je remonterais plus loin,
Emile.
Je crois qu'il y a une infinité
entre la France et l'Allemagne
sur des valeurs.
Ces valeurs, nous les avons
partagées pendant les Lumières.
Pour les Allemands,
l'Aufklarung,
des mouvements différents.
Des valeurs de liberté,
des valeurs de conquête
pour les peuples,
et jusqu'en 1848, nous avons
échangé, marché ensemble.
C'est le nationalisme
qui nous a fait diverger et aboutir
à ces guerres citées.
Et puis, en 1945, non seulement
on ne voulait plus faire de guerre,
mais on s'est rendu compte
que nous avions ce socle commun
de valeurs partagées,
autour du concept de liberté.
C'est très profond
entre les Français et les Allemands.
Nous devrions essayer
de le redécouvrir.
Nous vivons dans un monde
dont on dit qu'il est liberticide
par certains aspects.
La France et l'Allemagne
sont en avant,
s'agissant des combats
pour la liberté.
-Oui. Sur les couples ?
Si on peut utiliser ce terme.
-Moi, ce que je crois,
si on remonte...
-Pierre Lellouche ?
-Maurice a raison.
L'un des paradoxes de l'histoire
des deux derniers siècles,
c'est que nous, Français,
nous avons inventé
le nationalisme allemand.
C'est la Révolution française
et Napoléon
qui ont fabriqué, excusez-moi,
l'Allemagne de Bismarck.
C'est tout à fait regrettable,
parce qu'on l'a payé
lourdement après.
On aimait l'Allemagne éparpillée
en toutes sortes
de petits duchés avec lesquels
on s'alliait.
C'est nous qui l'avons unifiée.
Ensuite, la réunification
l'a réunifiée
et la question que je posais
dans un de mes livres,
il y a 30 ans, c'est :
"Que va-t-il se passer ?
L'Allemagne est unie."
Est-ce qu'elle va rester ancrée
dans la famille européenne ?
Elle n'a plus besoin de l'Europe.
Adenauer avait besoin de l'Europe...
...pour exorciser le passé,
pour trouver une nouvelle...
respectabilité internationale.
L'Allemagne d'aujourd'hui
n'a plus besoin de ça.
La guerre est très loin
et les nouvelles générations
ont oublié.
Donc, que va faire l'Allemagne,
surtout dans l'après-guerre
d'Ukraine ? C'est la question
stratégique de fond qui se pose
dans l'après-guerre
et dans le système de sécurité.
Est-ce qu'on va être capables,
nous, Français,
aujourd'hui affaiblis,
foutus dehors d'Afrique,
et par les Américains du Pacifique,
alors que nous avons
la Calédonie et Tahiti.
La façon dont les Américains
et les Anglais se sont conduits...
dans le Pacifique,
est invraisemblable. Les Russes
jouent leur rôle en Afrique.
Nous, on est affaiblis.
La question de fond,
je termine,
parce que c'est une
des questions cruciales
post-guerre, parce que j'essaie
de penser au monde d'après,
il y a la Russie, mais il y a
le rôle que l'Allemagne jouera
au centre de l'Europe.
Ou bien on est capables
de maintenir ce tandem,
ce mariage franco-allemand,
qui a été à la source
de la naissance
de l'Union européenne...
L'UE,
c'est la réconciliation
franco-allemande.
Ou bien on est capables
de cimenter ça dans quelque chose
qui va être très différent,
avec des Polonais,
des Baltes, des Balkaniques...
Ca va être ingérable.
Une Europe à 30, 35,
excusez-moi,
mais ça va être
très, très compliqué.
Il faut que ce pilier
franco-allemand soit hyper fort.
S'il n'est pas fort,
alors, le risque,
c'est qu'on bascule
dans d'autres formats,
où l'Allemagne devra
se poser la question
de ce qu'elle veut être
au milieu de l'Europe.
C'est un moment...
-Laissez-moi donner la parole,
si vous le permettez,
à Hans-Dieter Lucas.
Je voudrais un équilibre
de temps de parole.
Donc, je voudrais
vous poser deux questions.
On a évoqué un sentiment,
en France,
sur l'Allemagne.
J'aimerais que vous nous disiez,
peut-être même en oubliant
que vous êtes ambassadeur,
mais à votre avis,
qu'est-ce qu'on reproche,
vu de Berlin, à Paris ?
Et deuxièmement,
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que ce souffle historique,
politique, économique,
qu'il y a eu
avec les différents tandems,
n'est plus là aujourd'hui ?
-Tout d'abord,
je voudrais...
-Vous avez le droit
d'avoir des dissensions.
-Oui, oui.
Un petit point sur la question :
"Où va l'Allemagne ?"
C'est toujours cette discussion,
en France,
sur les incertitudes allemandes.
C'était une grande discussion,
dans le contexte
de la réunification,
et là, notre réponse,
c'était Maastricht, l'Europe.
A mon avis, ça n'a pas changé.
Donc, si on regarde,
par exemple, les résultats
des dernières élections législatives
en Allemagne,
85 % des Allemands ont voté
pour des partis pro-européens,
pour qui le couple
franco-allemand
est tout à fait central.
A mon avis, aussi,
si on regarde les sondages...
Les derniers sondages nous disent
que...
pour plus de 80 %
des Allemands,
la France est le partenaire
le plus important,
le plus fiable.
Donc, il y a là, à mon avis,
un sentiment européen très fort,
au sein de la population allemande,
de la classe politique,
qui ne met pas en cause
cette orientation classique,
si vous voulez,
de l'Allemagne
envers l'Europe,
avec un noyau dur franco-allemand
et le chancelier
l'a répété,
dans son discours à la Sorbonne,
où il a dit :
"Pour nous, la France,
c'est une nation indispensable."
En anglais
"Indispensable nation."
C'est un commentaire très fort.
Avec un certain intérêt,
je suis la discussion
sur la question :
"Est-ce que l'Allemagne s'oriente
"vers l'est ?"
Ca s'inscrit dans une...
-Ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit.
-Mais sur ce point-là, le centre
de gravité de l'Union européenne,
économiquement,
c'est l'Allemagne,
c'est la France,
c'est le Benelux,
l'Italie, l'Espagne,
avec l'importance de la Pologne,
et aussi...
de nos partenaires à l'est,
mais donc, vraiment,
un centre de gravité...
-Monsieur l'ambassadeur,
on dit ça,
mais il y a quand même
la réalité économique,
alors, permettez-moi
de vous dire...
"La relation franco-allemande,
"il y a eu Airbus,
Airbus, Airbus."
Quand on regarde, par exemple,
dans le domaine de l'informatique,
les relations de l'Allemagne
avec la Chine
sont privilégiées.
Si je ne me trompe pas,
Huawei alimente
la 5G allemande pour 60 %.
Et si on prend l'industrie
automobile allemande,
elle est extrêmement développée
en Chine,
et sa connexion informatique vient
quasi totalement de Huawei.
On a pensé, c'est ce qu'on écrit
dans les journaux
français
et dans les journaux allemands,
qu'il y avait là
une force pour l'Europe,
à travers le tandem franco-allemand.
Est-ce que vous êtes pas,
pas gênés, mais quand même...
Imaginons que demain,
il y ait une guerre avec Taïwan.
Comme nous avons la guerre
en Ukraine.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites
de Huawei ?
-Il y a, en ce qui concerne
la Chine, une discussion
en Allemagne,
depuis quelques années.
Disons que...
La Chine, ça reste un partenaire
très important.
Aussi très important
pour les questions dans le contexte
du changement climatique,
mais de l'autre côté,
il y a dans nos relations,
l'Europe, les Etats-Unis,
avec la Chine,
des éléments de compétition,
même de rivalité systémique,
d'où la nécessité, vraiment,
aussi, de repenser un peu
notre politique
vis-à-vis de la Chine.
C'est ce qu'on fait.
La Chine a changé. Il nous faut
changer aussi notre politique,
c'est-à-dire,
il nous faut diversifier aussi
nos relations commerciales.
Le chancelier, récemment,
était en Amérique latine.
Il a visité le Brésil,
le Chili, l'Argentine.
Il était au Vietnam.
C'est, pour nous,
une nécessité de diversifier
nos relations commerciales.
-Edouard Guillaud,
stratégiquement,
c'est gênant
que Huawei domine
le numérique en Allemagne ?
-Oui, forcément,
mais je crois que l'explication,
elle est assez simple.
Au moins,
jusqu'à ces derniers temps,
l'Allemagne a pensé
que le soft power,
la puissance douce,
la puissance économique,
se suffisait à elle-même,
et du coup,
quand on est dans cette optique,
aller chez Huawei ou un autre
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance.
A l'inverse, Poutine, lui,
pense que seul le hard power,
la puissance militaire,
sert à quelque chose.
Je pense que c'est
tout aussi différent.
Et cette opposition,
d'une certaine façon,
entre la position classique
française,
l'alliance du soft power
et du hard power,
qui fait une diplomatie,
qui fait une analyse stratégique,
et la position allemande,
qui est restée,
en train de changer
à cause des événements,
pas seulement en Chine,
mais en Ukraine,
c'est là la vraie...
non pas rupture,
mais le vrai fossé
qu'il a pu y avoir.
J'ai l'impression
qu'il est en train de se réduire,
mais quand vous pensez le monde
en termes de puissance,
vous ne mettez pas tous vos oeufs
dans le même panier.
Nous, Français,
comme les Britanniques,
nous avons toujours pensé le monde
en termes de rapports de puissance.
Je me souviens qu'au sein
du Quai d'Orsay, il y avait ceux
qui appartenaient à "la secte"...
...dont vous êtes et...
-Non. Ca dépend
de ce qu'on appelle "la secte".
-Non...
Ceux qui pensaient que
les rapports de puissance
sont importants.
Mais d'autres disaient :
"Non, c'est pas ça.
"C'est uniquement la culture."
"Uniquement l'économie."
Il y a un tout.
C'est cette différence d'analyse
sur le reste du monde.
Une fois que vous avez
cette différence,
vous avez des différences
de choix.
-Oui, mais...
ça n'est pas
qu'une différence de choix.
Si vous prenez la politique
énergétique de l'Europe,
elle n'existe pas.
Il y a une dissension...
très forte
sur la question du nucléaire.
Il y a eu des problèmes
au niveau de la taxonomie,
des investissements verts.
On a...
On a eu du mal à fixer un prix
de l'électricité abordable,
et les ménages,
des deux pays, d'ailleurs,
trinquent,
en payant très cher à cause
de la question du gaz.
Est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas régler
ces deux questions majeures
pour l'économie des deux pays,
à savoir le numérique et l'énergie,
en allant vers une politique
énergétique et numérique ?
Tous les deux.
-J'ai dit
tout à l'heure que ce qui s'était
passé depuis 20 ans,
depuis la réunification, notamment,
c'est le fait que l'Allemagne
s'est imposée comme le poids lourd,
le pivot de la politique européenne,
à mesure que nous déclinions,
de notre côté et donc,
on a eu de plus en plus de mal
à contrebalancer cette puissance.
Et cette puissance s'est manifestée
dans les domaines cités.
-Et qui sont primordiaux.
-Celle qui a
dicté l'accord commercial
entre l'UE et la Chine,
c'est Angela Merkel,
c'est elle qui l'a voulu.
Et l'accord a été paraphé,
tout à fait à la fin de l'année
2020, alors même
qu'il y avait beaucoup
de réserves côté français,
mais on n'a pas pu
l'empêcher.
Et cet accord était basé
sur l'idée que rappelait l'amiral,
à savoir que le soft power
devait amener
à un changement systémique
de la Chine,
ce qui était la même idée
quand on a fait entrer la Chine
à l'OMC...
-On verra que c'est la même chose
avec la Russie et l'OTAN,
d'ailleurs.
-Non, sur la Russie,
c'est autre chose.
Donc voilà, ça,
c'est un aspect des choses,
qui fait que,
avec la dépendance
de l'industrie automobile
allemande en Chine,
l'Allemagne a tiré
l'Union Européenne
vers une vision assez irénique
de ce qu'est la Chine.
L'autre point majeur dans lequel
l'Allemagne a vraiment
été l'architecte, à mon avis,
d'un désastre énergétique européen,
c'est quand l'Allemagne
s'est littéralement droguée
au gaz russe bon marché.
Et elle l'a fait parce que c'était
l'un des piliers
de son succès économique :
de l'énergie pas chère et sûre,
croyait-elle.
Et rappelez-vous,
c'est très intéressant,
le deuxième gazoduc,
Nord Stream 2,
a été décidé après l'annexion
de la Crimée,
pas avant, après.
C'est dire que,
c'est pas juste madame Merkel
ou monsieur Schroder,
toute la classe politique allemande,
toute l'industrie allemande a fait
le pari de ce mode énergétique,
renforcée par la montée en puissance
des Verts en Allemagne,
on ferme les centrales nucléaires.
J'étais là, avec madame Merkel,
quand elle nous a dit,
juste après Fukushima,
un soir,
à François Fillon et à moi :
j'arrête le nucléaire en France
et vous allez devoir
fermer Fessenheim.
Je lui ai dit qu'on était
encore un Etat souverain,
mais on a quand même,
un peu plus tard,
fermé Fessenheim
sous la pression de l'Allemagne.
Et donc ce poids majeur
de l'Allemagne sur tout
ce qui dicte le commerce,
l'énergie et bien sûr
la monnaie, aussi,
même si y a eu des évolutions,
est quelque chose
auquel nous n'avons pas su,
par notre propre faiblesse,
résister suffisamment.
On aurait d'ailleurs rendu service
aux Allemands en étant un peu
plus puissants dans le tandem.
Aujourd'hui,
la question qui se pose,
c'est que se passe-t-il après ?
Le chancelier Scholz,
dès le début de la guerre,
a dit que c'était
un moment tournant,
c'est le tournant
de la politique allemande,
on recommence tout.
Mais vers quoi et, nous,
nous sommes toujours à la recherche
de ce que nous allons devenir aussi.
Donc c'est pour ça
que j'en appelle vraiment,
et je suis pas un Européen béat,
j'ai vu la table
du Conseil européen,
je sais à quel point ça peut être
ingérable et souvent très décevant,
mais je sais que s'il y a pas
un tandem franco-allemand très fort,
et un accord sur le fond,
là, nous risquons
des choses très graves
à l'avenir dans ce post-Ukraine
qui risque de déliter
tout ce qu'il reste d'Europe.
-Hans-Dieter Lucas,
que répondez-vous à ce que dit
Pierre Lellouche
concernant la divergence très claire
sur la politique énergétique ?
-En ce qui concerne
la politique énergétique,
on a déjà tiré les leçons,
n'est-ce pas,
de cette dépendance dans la Russie,
c'est-à-dire qu'au cours...
Depuis le 24 février
de l'année dernière,
on est sortis complètement
du gaz russe,
du pétrole russe, du charbon russe.
-L'électricité reste
très chère.
-Sans provoquer une crise majeure
en matière d'énergie.
Mais maintenant,
on est en plein
dans ce processus
de la transition verte.
Et, pour nous,
la direction est assez claire.
Il faut bien entendu trouver
un accord sur la question
du marché de l'électricité,
n'est-ce pas,
donc vous avez mentionné
cette question-là,
mais ça a été aussi discuté
à l'occasion
du conseil des ministres
franco-allemand,
on a dit qu'il fallait
travailler ensemble là-dessus.
Je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous,
sur toutes ces questions-là,
il nous faut trouver un accord
franco-allemand, sachant bien que,
en ce qui concerne
la question du nucléaire,
nous sommes très différents,
ça fait partie de nos différences.
Mais il faut aussi apprendre
à vivre avec ces différences.
C'est possible, à mon avis.
-Oui.
-On est très différents sur le plan
de l'énergie et j'étais à Berlin
à l'époque où la chancelière Merkel
a décidé après Fukushima de sortir,
parce qu'il y avait déjà
une tendance lourde en Allemagne,
qui était anti-nucléaire,
pour des raisons historiques,
des raisons existentielles
de l'Allemagne.
Il faut être juste,
ce ne sont pas les Allemands
qui nous ont forcés
à décider de passer de 75 %
de production d'électricité à 50 %,
ce n'est pas eux,
ce sont des alliances politiques
en France qui nous ont amenés
à prendre ces décisions,
à voter une loi de programmation
énergétique toujours en vigueur,
pas eux qui nous ont
fait fermer Fessenheim
ou annoncer qu'on allait fermer
14 centrales et ensuite se lancer
un peu plus tard dans la crise
sur un programme,
nouveau programme du nucléaire.
Je pense qu'il faut être juste.
Nous avons une dissension
majeure non réglée,
Hans-Dieter Lucas a raison,
il faut arriver à recréer vite
un système qui permette de payer
le juste prix de l'électricité
car ça touche les peuples.
Mais ça, c'est les conséquences
de cette guerre en Ukraine
qui nous prend de plein fouet,
qui bouleverse
nos modèles économiques.
-Vous allez voir,
on va en parler mais,
Edouard Guillaud,
je voudrais aborder
avec vous une question
stratégique majeure.
Le président Joe Biden a fait
voter cette fameuse loi
qui s'appelle IRA
et qui est :
Inflation Reduction Act,
des centaines de milliards d'euros,
tout ça pour booster,
doper l'industrialisation
verte des Etats-Unis.
Alors on a vu que le ministre
français des Finances accompagné
de son équivalent allemand
sont allés à Washington.
Mais, franchement,
on est là devant
une bataille commerciale ?
-En bon français,
ça s'appelle la préférence nationale
et je le dis volontairement
sans aucune référence
de politique intérieure.
C'est ce que font les Etats-Unis.
Aujourd'hui, objectivement,
le Etats-Unis profitent
du conflit en Ukraine
pour vendre des armements...
-Du gaz.
-Pour vendre du gaz
naturel liquéfié,
dont le bilan carbone est
juste absolument épouvantable,
je n'ose même pas comparer
au nucléaire et, pour l'instant,
les Etats-Unis, stratégiquement
parlant, sont les gagnants
- je dis pas que, à terme,
c'est vrai, mais aujourd'hui -
les gagnants du conflit ukrainien.
-Mais sur ce green deal,
d'un côté,
et cette concurrence
commerciale imposée par Biden,
est-ce que,
monsieur l'ambassadeur d'Allemagne,
le moment n'est pas venu
de mutualiser la politique
économique et financière
de l'Union Européenne pour pouvoir
résister,
en termes de compétitivité,
avec les Etats-Unis, par exemple ?
-Tout d'abord, je ne vois pas
l'intérêt à entamer une guerre
commerciale avec les Etats-Unis.
Mais le fait que les Etats-Unis
misent sur la transition verte,
c'est principalement, à mon avis,
un bon message pour le climat,
n'est-ce pas, pour la question
du changement climatique.
Et en ce qui concerne
les aspects industriels,
je pense qu'il faut faire
deux choses :
donc essayer, n'est-ce pas,
d'obtenir des Américains
des exceptions, finalement,
créer une situation
dans laquelle nous sommes traités,
l'Europe,
comme le Mexique et le Canada ;
et le deuxième aspect,
c'est la question de rendre
l'Europe plus compétitive
et ça, c'est la question
des mesures
qu'on peut prendre,
sur la question
de la flexibilisation
des règles d'Etat,
je pense que c'est très important,
la question des...
Il faut agir beaucoup plus vite,
la Commission européenne
doit décider beaucoup plus vite
en ce qui concerne
les grands projets européens
et, finalement, il faut aussi,
comme vous l'avez dit,
n'est-ce pas, mobiliser
les ressources financières.
Donc il y a là,
dans les fonds qui existent déjà,
le plan de relance,
encore des moyens considérables,
c'est le Engie Europe,
le REPowerEU,
c'est la banque
d'investissement européenne.
Donc il n'y a pas, pour le moment,
un manque d'investissement.
Il faut aussi identifier
les bons projets.
-C'est pas nécessaire
d'avoir un fonds mutuel
pour concurrencer
ou se mettre en position
de ne pas être dépassé
par les Etats-Unis ?
-Ca a été proposé
par la Commission européenne,
l'idée de créer un fonds souverain,
mais tout d'abord,
donc s'il y a...
Si on se rend compte que...
Dans le plan de relance,
80 % des ressources
n'ont pas été dépensées,
donc il faut tout d'abord profiter
de ce qui est déjà là.
-Très bien,
Pierre Lellouche,
et on passera aux questions
de défense,
donc soyez concis,
si vous le voulez bien.
-Très concis.
J'ai, dans cette maison, en 2016,
ouvert le débat
sur l'extraterritorialité
des lois américaines
et comment l'Amérique
utilise son droit
pour casser la concurrence.
Là, ils viennent de passer une loi
ouvertement protectionniste
qui dit : "venez à moi,
les petits enfants,
"investir, si vous construisez ici,
vous aurez accès
"aux financements locaux".
C'est en fait une forme
de cannibalisme industriel
au moment même où nos entreprises
sont frappées par une explosion
du prix de l'énergie.
En Europe, c'est quatre à cinq fois
le prix aux Etats-Unis.
Donc la réindustrialisation
qui a été lancée en France,
avec beaucoup de mal,
d'ailleurs,
et l'industrie allemande puissante
sont prises en tenaille
entre l'augmentation du gaz
et le protectionnisme américain.
Il faut être capables,
Français et Allemands,
si j'étais aux affaires,
de répondre par la réciprocité,
parce que les Américains,
qu'est-ce qu'ils m'ont dit, moi ?
Ils m'ont dit que la loi
avait été votée,
circulez, y a rien à voir,
il fallait se plaindre avant,
ai-je entendu.
Donc quand Le Maire
et son collègue vont à Washington,
ils s'entendent dire :
séparation des pouvoirs,
la loi a été votée,
vous pouvez rentrer chez vous.
La seule chose que peut
faire d'utile l'Europe,
outre les investissements,
indispensables,
c'est de faire en sorte
que le jeu soit égal,
à savoir que nous soyons capables
de riposter par le même type
de dispositif.
Si on fait pas ça,
on sera balayés.
Et ce sera du cannibalisme
industriel, donc le moment est,
là aussi, assez grave,
et c'est très important.
-On vous a entendu.
Vous voulez ajouter un mot,
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne ?
-Je pense qu'il importe
que ce soit le ministre
français des Finances
et son collègue allemand
de l'économie qui soient ensemble.
Nous pesons à nous deux
47 % de la zone euro,
nous représentons
quelque chose qui pèse.
C'est mon expérience chinoise,
quand nous apparaissions,
Français et Allemands, ensemble,
notre voix comptait,
l'Allemagne par elle-même,
la France moins sur le plan
industriel et économique,
mais la combinaison
des deux est forte.
Les Américains le voient
aussi comme ça.
Et sur ce qu'il faut faire,
évidemment,
y a une certaine palette.
Se lancer dans une guerre
commerciale ?
Je ne crois pas, néanmoins,
la fermeté est quelque chose...
Nous sommes en voie de montrer,
Français
et Allemands en tête,
avec le soutien des Européens.
-Le moment est venu d'aborder
les questions de défense.
Une politique européenne de défense
et de sécurité commune,
c'est un projet
dont on entend parler matin,
midi et soir et notamment
avec la guerre en Ukraine.
-De moins en moins, ces jours-ci.
-Mais est-ce que,
à ce niveau,
la coopération doit
se faire entre la famille
intra-européenne ?
Quelle part doit avoir l'OTAN ?
Est-ce qu'on peut exclure
les Etats-Unis ?
Et, là-dessus,
il y a manifestement
des vues différentes
entre Paris et Berlin.
-Y a forcément un certain
nombre de vues,
liées à l'histoire,
à l'histoire militaire,
mais aussi à l'histoire politique.
Nous sommes obligés de constater
que l'OTAN a ressuscité,
grâce à l'agression russe
sur l'Ukraine,
parce que sinon,
l'OTAN était effectivement
en état de mort cérébrale,
et donc, on ne peut pas
éliminer l'OTAN.
Pour avoir par ailleurs
une politique de défense
et de sécurité commune,
la première chose est d'avoir
une analyse stratégique
et une compréhension
du monde partagées.
Et ça, à part la tentative
de Javier Solana
au milieu des années 2000,
depuis, il y a eu des petites
mises à jour mais qui, en réalité,
n'ont pas vraiment fait
avancer la réflexion.
Je constate des rapprochements,
depuis une quinzaine d'années,
et même si je remonte
au milieu des années 80,
parler à des stratèges
ou des stratégistes allemands
de ce qui se passait en Afrique
en disant qu'il fallait
faire attention,
c'était peine perdue :
on n'avait rien compris,
c'était de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée.
Ce n'est plus du tout le cas.
Donc y a eu non pas un rapprochement
des points de vue mais une prise
de conscience partagée
d'un certain nombre d'enjeux.
Le chemin n'est pas encore terminé.
Si on prend les contraintes
que sont l'OTAN,
le fait que nous n'avons pas
exactement encore
la même perception
de l'état du monde
et le fait aussi...
-Est-ce que l'Allemagne
est pas plus réaliste ?
-Très sincèrement,
c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure,
l'Allemagne étant peut-être
en train de changer,
mais étant partisane du soft power,
j'estime que c'était pas réaliste,
vu l'état du monde,
la Chine, les Etats-Unis,
la Russie le prouvent,
y compris l'Inde
vis-à-vis de la Chine
et pas juste vis-à-vis du Pakistan,
à un moment,
ce sont des rapports de puissance.
Et comme disent
les Britanniques et les Américains :
might makes right,
la puissance fait le droit.
Et tant que nous ne serons
pas d'accord,
on aura beaucoup de mal à avancer.
On peut avoir des petites
coopérations ponctuelles,
mais ça fait maintenant
plus de 15 ans qu'on n'a pas réussi
à déployer le bataillon
franco-allemand.
-Alors, on arrive,
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne,
à la question un peu fiévreuse.
La France et l'Allemagne soutiennent
l'effort de guerre en Ukraine.
On a même vu des réunions
communes entre Olaf Scholz,
Emmanuel Macron
et le président Zelensky.
La Grande-Bretagne
et les Etats-Unis font pareil.
Jusqu'où vous pensez
que la France doit soutenir
cette guerre
et est-ce qu'elle peut aller
jusqu'à une défaite de la Russie ?
Si on traduit ça simplement,
ça veut dire que les Russes quittent
ce qui ne leur appartient pas,
à savoir le Donbass
et peut-être la Crimée.
Parce qu'il faut bien dire...
-Vous avez bien posé le problème.
La question, c'est de savoir...
de faire en sorte
que l'Ukraine ne perde pas
et que l'Ukraine soit
dans une position
la plus forte possible
le jour où il s'agira
un jour de s'asseoir
à une table de négociations.
Pour le moment,
le terrain militaire n'est pas fixé,
on est dans l'escalade,
une escalade qui est
celle des Russes
et des Occidentaux,
de l'Ukraine
soutenant les Occidentaux.
Ce point culminant
n'est pas atteint.
Pour le moment,
les Etats-Unis
soutiennent l'Ukraine.
Je ne suis pas certain que,
dans le long ou le moyen terme,
les Etats-Unis soient
toujours de ce côté
car ils ont d'autres priorités :
la Chine
et l'économie américaine elle-même.
Quand on regarde les sondages
aux Etats-Unis,
l'Ukraine est bien moins
prioritaire qu'elle n'était.
-Elle n'est pas du tout
prioritaire.
-Et la chambre des représentants,
c'est important d'avoir en tête
les facteurs externes :
la chambre des représentants
a la main sur le budget
et est républicaine.
On va préparer les élections
présidentielles américaines.
Donc nous allons nous retrouver
avec l'Ukraine à gérer.
Il est très important d'envoyer
des signaux de soutien
à l'Ukraine mais des lignes rouges
à ne pas dépasser.
-Vous parlez de lignes rouges,
permettez-moi de vous dire que,
sur ce plateau,
nous avons eu beaucoup
de responsables français,
y compris de grands
écrivains qui étaient
russophiles et russophones,
par exemple
madame Carrère d'Encausse,
dans une émission
que j'ai tournée ici même,
a déclaré que Poutine
ruinait la Russie et ruinait
le peuple russe.
-Oui.
-Bon, si c'est le cas,
alors, ne faisons pas
de comparaisons
historiques dramatiques,
mais dans ce cas-là,
faut-il que la France et l'Allemagne
acceptent une défaite de la Russie
sur ce terrain-là ?
Je voudrais avoir vos avis,
messieurs Lucas et Lellouche.
-Je voudrais tout d'abord revenir
sur ce qui a été dit
en ce qui concerne le réalisme
allemand en ce qui concerne
les affaires stratégiques.
Je pense que vraiment,
pour nous, cette guerre,
cette agression russe est
un coup de semonce très sévère,
c'est la raison pour laquelle
le chancelier parlait
d'un changement d'époque,
n'est-ce pas,
la Zeitenwende,
et ça a eu des conséquences
très concrètes
sur le plan stratégique,
tout d'abord l'augmentation
massive de notre budget défense,
1000 milliards d'euros,
pour faire en sorte
que dans le futur
nous soyons capables
de dépenser
plus de 2 % du PIB
pour la défense,
donc c'est assez remarquable ;
deuxième point,
cette décision aussi historique,
n'est-ce pas,
de livrer des armes lourdes
à l'Ukraine.
On n'a jamais livré des armes
à un pays qui est en guerre
et qui n'est pas membre
de l'Union Européenne et de l'OTAN.
A mon avis, donc,
ça démontre vraiment un changement
dans la pensée stratégique
de l'Allemagne,
y compris
en ce qui concerne
la relation entre l'économie
et la géopolitique.
-Les chars aujourd'hui
et les avions demain ?
-Non, je voulais dire autre chose.
-Je vous ai dit que je pensais
que le fossé se réduisait.
-Il se réduit, parce que,
en Allemagne, on a toujours pensé,
c'était un peu le miracle allemand,
le miracle économique allemand,
de dire que l'économie
et la géopolitique étaient
des secteurs séparés.
Et maintenant, pour nous,
cela démontre qu'on ne peut pas
séparer ces deux secteurs.
En ce qui concerne
le soutien militaire
pour l'Ukraine,
donc on a pris cette décision,
n'est-ce pas,
de livrer des chars de combat,
les Leopard,
et notre position est
très claire : on va soutenir
l'Ukraine aussi longtemps
qu'il faudra.
-Jusqu'où ?
Jusqu'à ce qu'elle récupère
son territoire ?
-Je pense que ça,
c'est la demande partagée
de l'Union Européenne
et des Etats-Unis,
donc c'est la restauration
de l'intégrité territoriale.
-Mais Zelensky
a dit : en défendant l'Ukraine,
vous défendez l'Europe.
Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
On finit là-dessus.
Vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée ?
-La Russie a mis en cause
l'ordre européen
avec cette agression
contre l'Ukraine.
Et dans ce sens-là,
on fait en sorte
que la Russie ne gagne pas
cette guerre qui met
en cause l'ordre européen.
-C'est très clair.
Chacun donne son point
de vue là-dessus.
Edouard Guillaud, là-dessus ?
-La...
-L'Ukraine doit gagner
cette guerre ou pas ?
-Je vais le dire d'une façon
presque jésuite :
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre,
nous, européens,
que l'Ukraine perde.
Mais ne pas perdre ne veut pas dire
gagner,
c'est encore autre chose.
-Vous êtes militaire,
vous avez été le grand
patron de l'armée,
on gagne ou on perd
une guerre, bon.
-Non, malheureusement...
-Bon, mais laissez d'abord
le militaire s'exprimer.
-Le militaire,
c'est pouvoir stabiliser un front.
-Avec un territoire libéré ?
-Un territoire partagé.
Pensez au problème palestinien,
qui dure depuis 1947,
sous différentes formes,
on peut imaginer...
-C'est pas réjouissant.
-Non, c'est pas du tout réjouissant.
-C'est introduire
un conflit chronique
en Europe.
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne ?
On a très peu de temps.
-Y a d'autres conflits chroniques,
la Corée est partagée en deux,
ce n'est pas souhaitable
pour l'Ukraine.
Il y a un vrai sujet :
son intégrité territoriale,
son indépendance et sa souveraineté.
Le terrain militaire en décidera,
et le rapport de force,
avec le soutien
que nous donnons à l'Ukraine,
doit lui permettre
de s'en sortir au mieux
lors de négociations.
Elle ne peut pas perdre
sa souveraineté.
C'est le point central.
-Pierre Lellouche ?
-A mes yeux,
malheureusement,
à la suite de ce qu'a dit l'amiral,
mais différemment,
je crains que cette guerre
ne signe la fin du rêve français
de défense européenne.
Ce qui s'est passé au moment
du conseil des ministres
franco-allemand est tout à fait
révélateur de ça.
On était en pleine affaire
des Leopard,
des chars qui n'ont pas été
décidés par Macron et Scholz
mais trois jours plus tard
par Biden et Scholz,
après le sommet franco-allemand.
Donc clairement,
c'est les Américains
qui ont ouvert,
pour les Allemands,
une ombrelle, qui s'appelait
les chars Abrams, qui a permis
la livraison des Leopard,
mais ça s'est pas fait
en franco-allemand
et, de ce point de vue,
on voit bien que,
pour les Allemands,
le chef d'orchestre
de cette guerre
est à Washington.
Alors maintenant,
sur comment on termine cette guerre,
des décisions militaires
ont été prises tout le mois
de janvier d'intensifier,
de donner à l'Ukraine,
je cite les termes du Pentagone,
de mémoire :
de donner aux Ukrainiens
tous les moyens nécessaires
pour reprendre la dynamique,
qui est aujourd'hui bloquée,
on a un champ de bataille
qui est bloqué sur 1000 km,
donner aux Ukrainiens les moyens
pour percer la défense russe
et récupérer la totalité
de leur territoire.
Donc y a une sorte de surge,
on met des armes lourdes,
des véhicules blindés.
-Oui, mais donnez votre position,
parce que l'émission se termine.
-Ma position est simple,
je souhaite
qu'ils ne se trompent pas
et que cette offensive
ne conduise pas
à un engrenage hors contrôle
de la part de ceux
qui prennent les décisions.
-Alors, cette émission se termine,
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir.
Vous voyez que,
à partir du franco-allemand,
on arrive à la question européenne,
en quoi cet axe franco-allemand
demeure central mais,
aujourd'hui,
il est internationalisé
avec ce qui se passe,
et notamment
avec cette guerre en Ukraine.
Je voudrais citer
une brève bibliographie.
Y a quelques ouvrages
dont je voudrais parler,
y a un ouvrage
d'Hélène Miard-Delacroix
et Andreas Wirsching.
C'est deux chercheurs
français et allemand.
Un dialogue franco-allemand.
C'est très intéressant de voir,
dans le nuances comment
les deux pays peuvent se situer
sur l'état du monde.
Cette même relation franco-allemande
a été, depuis 45,
informatisée,
ça a donné lieu
à un document
du collège des Bernardins.
Là aussi, on a une vue
non pas synthétique
mais à la fois
singulière et globale
de cette relation franco-allemande.
Maurice Gourdault-Montagne,
vous avez publié ceci.
C'est typiquement,
j'allais dire, pardonnez-moi,
une expression de diplomate.
-Oui, bien nécessaire,
parce qu'on a tendance
à projeter ce que nous sommes
sur les autres,
qui ne sont pas comme nous.
-Pierre Lellouche, vous,
c'était bien avant l'Ukraine,
mais vous y pensiez déjà ?
-Disons que je me suis occupé
de l'Ukraine depuis 30 ans
de façon très assidue.
Ce qui m'amuse aujourd'hui,
c'est de voir tous les spécialistes
d'Ukraine qui n'y ont jamais
mis les pieds, quoi.
L'Ukraine a été un grand blanc
dans l'histoire de l'Europe
ces 30 dernières années.
-Comme quoi, l'Ukraine est un pays
important aujourd'hui.
Bah, écoutez,
il me reste à vous remercier,
merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé à cette émission,
merci à l'équipe de LCP d'être là,
avec nous, pour l'enregistrer.
Avant de nous quitter,
je vous laisse
avec cette citation
de Jean-Pierre Jouyet :
"Les relations entre
la France et l'Allemagne
"et entre leurs dirigeants
n'ont jamais été simples
"dans le cadre
de l'Union Européenne."
-Voilà qui est profond.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA